hey what's up guys mkbhd here and
motorola is back in the flagship
smartphone game
do you realize how long it's been and to
be honest i kind of miss these you know
it wasn't that long ago that i remember
the moto x and the droid series being
super competitive and unique and and
just motorola in general bringing a
certain spice to the high-end flagship
game before their absence but then they
didn't make one for a couple years so
they did budget phones for a while and
they dropped a folding phone
but now it's 20 20 and they're back with
a flagship so what do they pack in well
snapdragon 865 12 gigs of ram 256 gigs
of fast ufs 3.0 storage and a 5 000
milliamp hour battery there's a triple
camera on the back headlined by a 108
megapixel main shooter this thing's got
5g radios and it's capped off with a 6.7
inch 90 hertz oled display that is
massively curved around the sides hence
the name edge plus so there's a lot of
good things here but it's far from
perfect and there are some things that
are frustrating that sort of feel like
come from motorola being rusty making
flagship phones
and we got to talk about the whole curve
display thing but first of all i mostly
really like the way this phone is built
you know it's metal and glass like any
other flagship and it has some character
with the curves in the top and bottom
rails that i like
and yes you're not seeing things that is
a headphone jack on a flagship phone in
2020 one of the last you'll find
speaker at the bottom that's paired with
the earpiece at the top to my ear gets
pretty loud and sounds really good but
what's funny is even as thick as this
phone is the camera bump on the back for
those huge cameras still sticks out even
more and since it's off to the side yes
it absolutely still rocks on a table
classic but the one thing i dislike the
most isn't the camera bump or the
fingerprint magnet that is the back of
this phone but it's because this display
this waterfall display so dramatically
curves over the edges like the huawei
mate 30 pro
it pushes the buttons on the side of the
phone back from the center so they're
not in the middle anymore they're like
pushed back even further from the middle
where they'd usually be and also i
usually like when the volume buttons are
on the opposite side of the phone as the
power button but they're all on one side
here but i guess that's something you
can pretty easily get used to oh you
know what else i recently noticed when
you shake this phone
aside from turning on the flashlight it
makes this noise you hear that
so i thought that noise was coming from
the buttons like rattling inside the
phone which is like oh that's not very
good
quality that's not very good feeling but
you still get that noise
when you hold the buttons down turns out
that noise is coming from the giant
camera and the optically image
stabilized sensor inside the back of the
phone here i verified that because the
same sort of system in the galaxy s20
ultra
also makes this
rattling noise so anyway it's not an
actual fault of the phone i just felt
like pointing it out because i noticed
it um these sensors are getting huge
also
don't shake your phone that much i
missed the motorola flagship software
treatment like a lot there's not that
many like it but it's really nice it's
relatively clean android 10 with
motorola features added that's always
what i loved about those previous
motorola flagships if you go back and
watch those old reviews this is almost
the same thing you have the motorola
actions the double chop to turn on the
flashlight the double twist to quickly
open the camera app and all that stuff
is still here there's also motorola's
couple widgets including this time and
weather one on the home screen with this
weirdly low frame rate animation
but it's still pretty much mostly what i
would expect but i guess they've gotten
a bit rusty because this verizon
exclusive phone has more bloatware
pre-installed than i've seen on any
premium phone in a long time i actually
didn't uninstall any of them yet so you
can see them all here but it came with
all these games two different versions
of candy crush um the verizon cloud app
a digital secure app there's disney plus
and then another game
and then another game
sheesh i i didn't know initially if this
is a verizon thing or a motorola thing
probably a verizon thing uh but yeah of
course you can just go through and
uninstall them all one by one but it
just doesn't feel
premium when you have to go through that
also one other little thing that doesn't
feel flagship quality on this phone is
the vibration motor something that's
underrated on a lot of those really good
phones this one has one that's kind of
rattly and doesn't feel that great on
par with like 400 phones i wish it was
better but the battery is one thing i
can't complain about though five
thousand milliamp hours is here it's a
huge sell and that's a trend i'm happy
to see continuing in these flagships and
it's translated well i was getting
regularly six plus hours of screen on
time which is awesome and it was lasting
through the end of the day with battery
to spare which is what matters and i
guess that makes perfect sense for a
phone with a 1080p display and such a
huge battery and there's also wireless
charging and it comes with a decently
fast charger in the box the one thing
i'd be hesitant about well not hesitant
really just just to keep in mind
is this is a 5g phone that's one of
their main focuses of it on verizon
which
cool great um but i'm not in a 5g area
you might have seen my 5g explain video
where i was testing verizon's millimeter
wave 5g if not i'll leave it below the
like button but basically i live near
new york city which is one of those
cities that's lighting up with 5g now
but that millimeter wave does not reach
here from there so i've been using this
as a 4g phone basically since then so
that means someday in the theoretical
future they'll be lighting up 5g around
here and then this phone will connect to
that and it'll start getting those
better speeds but also that will draw
more battery life
you know how much more we don't know but
that's why 5g phones have all had mostly
bigger batteries um but generally 5000
million powers i'm not complaining and
then this camera
108 megapixels now you might be thinking
wait a second we've seen that number
before and you'd be right galaxy s20
ultra me note 10 this is another 108
megapixel main camera and for the most
part it's pretty similar to samsung's
camera matter of fact the colors are
quite nice and the shots are very
detailed as you'd expect dynamic range
is nice with auto hdr as well and it's
spitting out 27 megapixel photos by
default and basically if you give it a
little light you get good shots but it
struggles again i have to mention this
with the sensor being so huge
and the super shallow depth of field
that comes with that especially with
closer up subjects you've heard me say
this before but you know sometimes a
shallow depth of field looks cool i've
raved about that in the past but to a
certain limit look at this photo i took
of a sign
it's crazy it looks normal at first but
the left side of the sign is sharp and
in focus but the right side is a little
out of the plane of focus so it's blurry
sheesh now you've probably heard me talk
about this before but the real problem
here is motorola's viewfinder in their
camera app
sharpens the crap out of whatever you're
taking a photo of it looks it's like
cranked
to a hundred like you know that
lightroom clarity filter or if you just
turn sharpness all the way up it looks
like an effect so the sharpness is
exaggerated literally to a point where
you can't actually tell looking through
the viewfinder if you're nailing focus
or not i took shots like this by
pointing and shooting thinking focus was
fine because it was sharp in the
viewfinder but then when i looked at the
picture closely and i saw what happened
i had to take it again and this happened
multiple times here's a screenshot of
the viewfinder of what i'm seeing
and then the photo that i got and again
when you zoom in a bit you realize
it's a bit out of focus and you have to
actually look at the photo to realize
and take another picture you can
legitimately actually miss focus if you
don't check motorola why are you
sharpening the viewfinder this much you
have a good camera
tone it down relax
but also i feel like
we could use that dual aperture feature
again anyway before i rant about this
curved screen let's cool down a bit with
a message from this video sponsor honey
so we're all doing a lot more of our
shopping online nowadays so thanks to
honey saving money during this process
is now easier than ever because honey is
an online shopping tool that will find
promo codes and apply them to your cart
so in just a few clicks you install the
honey plug-in and your browser of choice
chrome safari whatever it is and then
whatever site you're on your favorite
websites target walmart newegg when
you're checking out this little box
drops down all you have to do is click
apply coupons wait a few seconds for it
to scan promo codes across the internet
and then watch the prices drop in case
you're wondering i started using honey
this year and i've already saved money
on some of the stuff i'm using to build
up this new studio and i will continue
to use it because i need a lot more
acoustic paneling and that's the sort of
thing you can save a lot of money on and
honey has found it's over 17 million
users over 2 billion
in savings and supported at more than 30
000 different stores online it's like by
not having honey you could literally be
passing up on free money and who would
do that it's free easy to install takes
two clicks so what are you waiting for
get honey for free right now like today
at joinhoney.com
mkbhd that's joinhoney.com
mkbhd and thanks to honey for sponsoring
this video
all right
we got to talk
about curve displays so this phone is of
course leaning into it pretty hard
there's some edge display features
that'll glow when you get a notification
when your alarm clock goes off the whole
side thing they really love it uh they
also named the phone the edge plus
but
can we stop i hope the world can see now
what's really going on out here because
it's getting ridiculous it's really
ridiculous like there was a day a few
years ago where every smartphone display
was pretty much flat but as we start to
reach out towards those edges and shrink
the bezels a bit samsung tried one of
the sides rolling over the edge because
hey there's samsung and they can try
stuff tossed a news ticker and some
stocks over there and some quirky
features on the side and suddenly it was
a hit people loved it because it looked
cool and next thing you know their next
phone has both the sides flowing over
the edges and we're loving it and other
companies are scrambling to figure out
how can we get our displays to do that
too meanwhile accidental touches start
to become a thing but you know what it's
early they'll iron that out
but that never really fully got ironed
out now don't get me wrong it still
looks super cool that's the whole point
it's this is prime form over function
but it turns out that curve over the
edges
it doesn't really seem to be worth the
extra cost and the extra accidental
touches we still get no matter how much
they've worked on this palm rejection
software and so now if you look back at
samsung's newest flagships the galaxy
s20 is one of the first ones going back
to flatter displays turns out it's okay
to roll back on some things we had
capacitive buttons at the bottom of
phones for a long while before we just
stopped that completely you don't see it
anymore we've had
ring flashes we've had branded bezels
we've had flaps over ports for better
water resistance but all of those things
we slowly realized there's better ways
to do that or this isn't the best idea
and now they're gone
it's okay to roll back on things and so
this is my formal petition to realize
that these curved over screens at least
these extreme ones these 90 degree
waterfall edges
we can work it back
thanks for coming to my ted talk
also not to pile on but this is the
worst fingerprint reader
i've ever seen under glass ever like i
really don't know what happened here
i've tried re-registering my fingerprint
twice using a different finger
but this reader gives me the most failed
attempts and the slowest average speed i
have ever seen in an in-glass
fingerprint reader so couldn't leave
that out so to sum it all up
i've liked using this phone
but i didn't love it and when you start
to shop around and compare it like the
oneplus 8 pro that i just came from has
a higher resolution a higher refresh
rate screen a better quality screen
overall turns out about the same quality
camera system
uh much faster charging there's the same
specs a better fingerprint reader
cleaner software no bloatware fast
software updates
and less of a curve around the screen so
you know the smaller battery is maybe
the only downside but
what reason is there
to buy the moto for 9.99 i just think it
falls in that category of phones that
you'd be okay with using if you got it
but there are other better phones to buy
out there and i think someone's got to
say it it's really just time to be done
with those curved displays and i don't
think motorola is done by any means with
trying out flagships i think they'll be
back
at least i hope so
either way that's been it thanks for
watching
catch you guys in the next one
peace